und jetzt heißt es nochmal haltung
annehmen und hand aus der hose in etwas
mehr als einer stunde ist es soweit zum
ersten mal in der geschichte verlässt
ein land die europäische union und zwar
großbritannien genau partystimmung große
stimmung bei den exit fans aber auch in
brüssel findet heute um mitternacht wohl
eine symbolische aktion staat ja da wird
extra eine britische fan an einen
bestimmten brunnen gelegt ein bereits
als zeichen als zeigen ich muss sagen
ich sehe es anders ich finde es traurig
ich weiß nicht wie es eben geht ich
finds auch traurig denn es gibt so
vieles was man an den briten einfach
lieben muss die bilder jetzt wieder
hochkommen ihr legendäres rhythmusgefühl
wir hier theresa may versucht hat das
wort exit zu tanzen ihre beneidenswerte
debattenkultur im unterhaus und
natürlich immer wieder ihre sportliche
fairness hier ein symbolbild für boris
johnson politik keine angst das kind ist
tot
und das traurige ist obwohl er jetzt
noch diese übergangszeit kommen bis zum
ende des jahres in der wir einen
freihandelsvertrag mit denen aushandeln
müssen jetzt schon kostet der brh exit
arbeitsplätze ja wirklich ich zum
beispiel habe hier alleine drei autoren
angestellt und zwar nur für exit witze
was mache ich jetzt mit diesen leuten
dass es ist ein hartes business
spare ihre gebühren von den von den
vielen grafiken hier mal ganz zu
schweigen hier wirklich jede woche einen
kracher nach dem anderen raushauen haben
wissen sie noch die toten hirne von
london oder der exorzist
und natürlich der klassiker planet der
insel offen ist alles vorbei alles
vorbei
denn
man wird mir lakonisch ich bin mir
lakonisch übrigens ironie der geschichte
heute müssen sich die briten ein
allerletztes mal nach uns richten braig
cit ist um 0 uhr mitteleuropäischer zeit
des motherfuckers ja was passiert dann
genau was 23 uhr britischer zeit ist
alle etwas komme uhrzeit und deshalb
sollte eigentlich bänder zu leuten statt
des big ben bongo reduziert nur eine dia
projektionen in der downing street geben
ist billiger das fängt ja gut an muss
ich sagen nein aber es richtig richtig
halte so erhält man lieber zusammen ihr
werdet es noch brauchen denn fakt ist
die briten wickeln etwa die hälfte ihres
handelns mit eu-ländern die hälfte und
wie das dann gehen soll eigene standards
für natürlich niedrigsteuern sie wollen
eine steueroase werden oder
arbeitnehmerrechte eigene
arbeitnehmerrechte aber weiter vom eu
binnenmarkt profitieren
wie das gehen soll das kann auch der bus
nicht erklären vielleicht wird das alles
noch viel viel teurer als gedacht und
weil bei uns in deutschland tatsächlich
kein mensch mehr bock hat auf das thema
exit konzentriert sich inzwischen 97
prozent unserer england
berichterstattung auf den sogenannten
exit der max it sie wissen schon harry
und merken also der arbeitslose
zeitsoldaten die arbeitslose
schauspielerin
die haben ja quasi gekündigt bei der
queen die sind quasi abgehauen
es muss man muss man so sagen und
seitdem
seitdem wirklich nur noch schnappatmung
dürfen die das mit gerade mal mitte
dreißig ausziehen
bei der oma und einer
wachsfigurenkabinett von madame tussauds
ist der bruch schon vollzogen die sussex
es stehen jetzt in der bücherecke weit
weg vom rest der windsors oder das ist
hat bücherecke haben wir jetzt eben auf
den bildern gar nicht so gut gesehen
aber die stehen da tatsächlich neben
hitler und stalin des zu haben ja das
geht soweit einfach nur weil sie
gekündigt haben ich finde es traurig vor
allem die aggressionen die mengen
entgegenschlagen sind ja wenn man
darüber nachdenkt geradezu ein symbol
für diesen braig sieht einen kulturkampf
zwischen einem weltoffenen modernen
england und der kleinen mäßigen insel
die lieber im eigenen genpool vor sich
hin gammeln will reden wir darüber in
einer neuen folge vorne holte show royal
ts mit christian seel manier
[Musik]
unser heute schon adelsexperte ist
menschlich enttäuscht ja christian
geradezu beleidigt wegen des max it kann
man wohl sagen werke das kann man wohl
sagen der familienbetrieb der winzer ist
das war auch die letzte erfolgsmarke der
bankrotten insel und plötzlich gibt es
diese unfassbare pressemitteilung der
queen zitat harry und medien sind ab
sofort nicht mehr arbeiten der
mitglieder der königlichen familie
totaler schock
wussten sie dass einer von ihnen jemals
gearbeitet ich auch nicht arbeit was ist
denn das das ist nicht mehr mein
hochadel arbeit in diese leute wollen
wir doch unsere träume unsere sehnsüchte
projizieren dafür sind jedoch da sie
sollen sich auf ihre kernkompetenzen
konzentrieren also polo und inzest was
soll denn da
dafür lieben wir sie doch dass sie so
völlig lebens und wichtig sind hier ein
ex-sportler verpetzt prinz charles
über die zahnpasta jeden morgen auf die
zahnbürste gedrückt und seine
schlafanzüge jeden morgen gebügelt auch
seine schnürsenkel müssen jeden morgen
gebügelt und geglättet werden
naja natürlich mit ungezügeltem
schnürsenkeln kommt er keine drei
mitarbeiter bricht sich das genick
alles wunderbar eingespielte uralte
rituale und dann kommt da so eine b
schauspielerin aus hollywood und sprengt
die gruppe kein wunder dass die medien
sich so ein bisschen auf sie
eingeschossen haben merken war er die
treibende kraft hinter diesem wir wollen
in royale rente geht und halten sie
persönlich für eine inzwischen eine
gefährliche person harry sehen waren
irgendwie nennen es in vancouver und
schockt häuser aber ich glaube
gleichzeitig dass sie einem unfassbar
selbst zentriert der egoistische person
ist belgien hat kate zum weinen gebracht
monster melden bricht das herz der queen
und was soll denn das warum kriegt sie
eigentlich fast alles alleine ab weil
sie die frau ist
so ein erfahrungswert von mir
weiß es ja noch die frau schuldig ja
auch gar nicht der punkt ja aber dass da
manche leute jetzt rassismus
reininterpretieren das finde ich einfach
lächerlich gut was man zugeben muss kate
und merken werden medial schon
unterschiedlich dargestellt hier
der britische express schreibt william
shatner avocado gegen die morgenübelkeit
und dann derselbe express mergens
geliebte avocado schuld an
menschenrechtsverletzungen dann halt
verschiedene avocados oder daily mail
nicht mehr lange schwangere kate
streichelt zärtlich ihren babybauch und
dieselbe zeitung zu schwangeren mengen
warum kann man nicht die finger von
ihrer blau zu lassen das hat aber
rechtliche frage was soll das ständige
gefummelt ja man ist ein gutes stichwort
selbst der notgeile prinz andrew kriegt
weniger ab in der britischen schweine
presse ja ja das kommt mal vor bei denen
winzers dass einer seinen kleinen
prinzen nicht unter kontrolle hat aber
das spielt doch letztlich keine rolle
ich sage ihnen die werden sich auch
wieder berappeln weil es ja letztlich
ein wirtschaftsunternehmen ist experten
schätzen den wert der marke winzer immer
noch auf 79 milliarden euro
was meinen sie was nicht verdienen mit
ihrem ganzen merchandising tennis teller
tassen royale nach tipp für das ganze
programm
da können unsere bürgerlichen politiker
nicht waren klingeln liegt doch alles
seit jahren wie blei bei uns im
heute-show fanshop der frank walter
steinmeier thermomix
aber war es sehr wichtig auch hier
die heiko maas beauty nacht geben will
keiner hat der größte laden wieder von
hallen dass anja karliczek katzen gut
deswegen
[Applaus]